figaro live bonjour bienvenue 10h50
souvenez vous cette petite boule au
ventre juste avant de découvrir le sujet
de philosophie du bac sur lequel vous
aviez vous faire des noeuds au cerveau
pendant près de quatre heures à aller
souvenirs on en rigole maintenant mais à
l'époque c'était pas facile et bien deux
journalistes du figaro ont accepté de se
replonger de faire replonger dans leurs
années lycée aujourd'hui à ma gauche la
magicienne de la pensée la dialecte riz
ciel du boulevard haussmann à nietzsche
dans chaque jambe elle a l'habitude de
ne faire qu'une bouchée de ses
adversaires surtout à lunettes un jeudi
madeleine m'étais bonjour bonjour
thibault merci d'être là madeleine
journaliste parentalité au figaro et
puis à ma droite le petit prince de la
rhétorique l'équarrisseur du débat de
plateau la légende dit qu'il aurait
inspiré spinoza et que socrate baisse
les yeux quand il le croise dans les
couloirs du figaro bonjour paul sujet
bienvenus bonjour ça vous va non non ça
ne veut pas du tout je vous sens très
stressée merci à tous les deux d'être là
alors on explique ce qu'on va faire ce
matin c'est très simple bac de philo en
ce moment même en les élèves sont en
train de plancher les sujets sont sont
tombés il y en avait 2 ans en bac
général de dans le bac technologique
nous en avons sélectionné trois je vous
les donne revient-il à l'état de décider
ce qui est juste c'est le deuxième sujet
du bac général la liberté
consiste-t-elle à n'obéir à personne
sujet 1 du bac techno et puis les
pratiques artistiques transforme-t-elle
le monde ça c'est le sujet 1 s'il vous
plaît pas beaucoup si j'ai bien compris
n'est pas révisée non vous n'avez pas
réalisé j'ai bien vu vous avez planché
alors ce pas facile lorsqu'on leur a
demandé de faire à tous les deux on
commence alors vous avez su choisi vous
madeleine le premier sujet lui vous
inspire revient-il à l'état de décider
ce qui est juste c'est le premier sujet
qu'on aborde je vous laisse commencer si
ça vous va alors ça m'inspire c'est un
grand oui donc si j'avais été une élève
médiocre c'est à dire ce que je suis à
peu près maintenant puisque j'ai révisé
ce matin dans le métro en regardant
vaguement les 17 concept que les élèves
ont eu à réviser la nature le travail la
liberté je n'ai pas réviser la liberté
parce que j'ai peu de stations de métro
jusqu'au travail et bien donc je suis
dans l'état d'un élève médiocre et c'est
donc le sujet qui m'inspire le plus
parce que c'est un sujet très classique
je pense que c'est un sujet qui est déjà
tombé plusieurs fois ces dernières
années disons qu'en tout cas le thème
l'homme évoque toutes les annales du oui
à la peau saine gestion vous avez fait
pas cher précise qu on a été prévenu
hier soir donc alors comment on y va
d'un sujet allez-y dites moi alors
revient-il à des tas de décider ce qui
est juste vous poserez 13 en partant on
n'est pas ici entre professeurs de
philosophie c'est à dire qu'on va pas
proposer un corrigé non on en est bien
incapable on l'a vous mais ce qui est
important pour les élèves qui nous
regarderait en se demandant s'ils ont
bien fait c'est de décortiquer
évidemment les termes du sujet et donc
celui qui est le plus important qui nous
pose un problème ici c'est le terme de
juste parce que qu'est ce qui est juste
et de justice on le sait et la justice
antoine le sait le bras de l'état
c'est-à-dire l'institution de la justice
qui en fête organise les rapports entre
les hommes au nom d'une vertu morale et
il ya la justice au titre de conscience
personnelle et morale ce qui me paraît
juste à moi ce que je décide être le
bien voilà et si je dis que c'est un
sujet classique c'est pas du tout parce
que j'ai épluché les annales lui même ce
que j'ai une vague connaissance des
sujets de ces dernières années pas du
tout c'est parce qu'un exemple m'est
tout de suite venue hanter rituel forte
heureusement l'exemple plus classique si
vous l'avez cité vous pouvez pas avoir
tort c'est l'exemple de sueur qui vous
vient thibault
c'est un boulot
non on ne m'embêtait pas aller je suis
sûr que vous allez me convaincre colle à
la cites vous dit l'état relative parce
qu'on a réussi ensemble
très bien c'est l'exemple d'un crayon et
d'antigone antigone seppi c'est la nièce
de crayon alors elle vient en deuxième
partie d'émission antigone aller
exactement va pas très bien
john dites-moi créons créons le roi
d'antigone sa nièce fille de deep et joe
caste qui est à la fois sa mère et sa
grand mère mais c'est une autre histoire
créon et le roi antigone est une jeune
femme fiancée office de créon voulait
rex et des rapports entre cousins c'est
un peu tordu c'est la grèce antique on
aime énormément ça il sait pas ce que
les deux frères d'antigone qu'elle aime
énormément se disputent s'entretuent les
deux frères d'antigone dont j'ai noté
les noms étaient au clae polynice était
ok polynice s'entretuent et leurs deux
corps restait tendue créon qui en
apprécient un décide de lui donner une
sépulture cette époque pour polynice pas
de sépulture sont corrélés c'est là il
servira à nourrir les corbeaux c'est la
loi crée on décide en tant
qu'organisateur des rapports humains
dans la société il décide que parce que
polynice est un voyou un brutal il ne
mérite pas d'être enterré c'est donc
pour le plus grand bien de tous si on
donne une sépulture aux voyous et au
brutaux qu'est ce qu'on dit on dit qu
être un voyou et un brutal est permis or
ça met en danger la société antigone
brûlante de patients d'émotion voire un
thé dansant très je comprends voilà
logiquement quand on est une adolescente
de 17 18 ans ça nous parle on penche
vers antigua et justement si on a un peu
de coeur on plonge vers antigone donc on
consomme sans coeur ici pas les cinq
heures vous le dis tout de suite on
pourra savoir qu'il est son père
conférence alors paul peut-être que vous
pouvez nous expliquer la position de
crayon oui il m'a elle est très
intéressante la police concurrencer la
raison d'état fassent effectivement à
l'emportement du coeur c'est aussi ce
qu'on retrouve dans le drame de titus et
béni bérénice est ce que je dois épouser
celle que j'aime ou est ce que je dois
être fidèle au peuple danger lagarde en
tant que son chef la raison d'état est
là elle a ses propres à sa propre
légitimité sa propre justice et je
trouve que la distinction que madeleine
à fait autres et des bus est vraiment
passionnante parce qu'effectivement on a
quasiment deux conceptions antagonistes
de la justice dans le restic vous faites
et la question c'est de savoir si elles
peuvent se réconcilier
mais ils paraissent moi je vous vois
bien s'y faire prendre d'un coût de
férus professoral sur mes petits doigts
d'adolescents khâgneux et donc je je je
pense que le sujet nous invite essayé de
réconcilier ces deux justice c'est à
dire au fond est ce qu il m'apparaît
possible de remettre à l'état une part
des décisions
qui concernent ce que j'appelle le juste
et l'injuste et ce qui me semble
historiquement c'est que à mesure qu'on
a justement fait évoluer le concept de
justice et même que on lui a
possiblement donner de plus en plus de
l'ampleur c'est à dire qu'on a élargi le
champ de la justice et ce sont des
considérations de ce qui est juste ou
injuste et bien l'état lui-même
justement a pris de plus en plus
d'importance en quelque sorte comme si
l'histoire de la construction moderne de
l'état et l histoire justement de son
élargissement à mesure que l'on faisait
à rentrer dans le champ de la justice
des préoccupations de plus en plus
sophistiqués permettent effectivement
permettez-vous aujourd'hui l'état
contemporain l'état moderne ça a
commencé à l'état moderne pense qu'il a
en fait compris les inclinations de son
peuple et qu'il a compris ce qu'il
fallait c'est un état de droit à partir
de là ils considèrent qu'ils appliquent
le droit tel qu'il a été voté par le
peuple qui est infaillible disait
rousseau et quand ça sa justice est
toujours bonne puisqu'elle a été décidée
par le peuple qui l'a élu qui a élu ses
représentants etc etc alors bravo madame
je vous coupe parce qu'il est là parce
que bon moi je suis très prosaïque
il m'intéresse particulièrement ce sujet
qu'on est en train de débattre et vous
pouvez réagir sur sur lefigaro.fr sur
youtube surtout sur facebook on est
partout donnez nous votre avis
revient-il à l'état de décider ce qui
est juste tiens donc ça colle
particulièrement à l'actualité quand
même pardon de vous ramener à ça mais
c'est peut-être intéressant les choix de
l'état pendant la pandémie le néracais
et c est ce que ce sujet là il n'est pas
choisie pour ça pour traiter cette
actualité qui nous est venue en pleine
figure l'année dernière et qui continue
à se développer en ce moment alors je
pense que c'est c'est une tendance des
élèves de croire que le sujet est
toujours là d'actualité alors que la
philosophie répond aux questions que
l'homme se pose depuis qu'il est homme
c'est à dire que c'est répondra en fait
un contre balancement entre deux force
très puissante à savoir la justice
est-elle notre conscience la justice
est-elle le bras de l'état je ne pense
pas que ce soit fait pour faire écho à
l'actualité il n'empêche que ça peut
évidemment faire résonance ça peut
intéresser les élèves et surtout
peut-être leurs parents à ces titres là
alors je ne vais pas aujourd'hui tranché
en vous disant si l'état une raison ou
non d'un procès parce que je vous
demande votre rapport difficultés là
dessus ce que je voudrais interrogé moi
c'est la question en fait la notion même
de l'état les cas on en fait on en parle
comme une entité pur une entité pure qui
serait en fait constitué de toutes les
petites volonté des êtres humains qu'ils
ont constituée qui l'ont élu qui sont en
fait à ses pieds or l'état n'est pas une
entité pur l'état est habitée par des
hommes des hommes sont à sa tête créon
est à la tête de l'état face à antigone
un soir créon est aussi une conscience
personnelle sauf qu'il habite l'état qui
lui est impersonnelle et qui décide et
qui à la fin tranche or créé on peut se
tromper
levis habite l'homme levis peut habiter
crime l'état peut donc se trompait en
salle peut être tout à fait légitime
même digne même nécessaire de s'opposer
à l'état alors pour ma part j'ai
toujours fait partie de la team antigone
comme disent les jeunes on dit souvent
ça va choisir votre camp ah j'ai
complètement choisi mon camp parce que
je pense que ce qui reste à la fin c'est
la conscience de l'homme en fait
finalement c'est ce qu'on a c'est notre
plus grand bien et si jamais on a
l'impression de la trahir au nom de
l'état c'est de l'asservissement
et l'asservissement c'est le début de l'
état totalitaire a justement on y vient
à quel moment on rentre on entre dans
l'autoritarisme
revient-il à l'état de décider ce qui
est juste mais poutine ce qu'il fait en
russie c'est juste ah bah c'est la
grande question qui à mon avis ils
méritent d'être interrogés on a un peu
parlé aussi avec madeleine quand on a
préparé hâtivement le sujet après la
découvert il faut bien dire aussi que
les sujets sont gardés secrets pendant
mans c'est normal ce que les élèves
pourront rentrer en retard à l'épreuve
et donc si les médias ont des cheveux
décortiquer les sujets avant qu'ils
arrivent dans la salle c'est qu'il ya un
problème donc on a eu les sujets il ya
quelques minutes et on s'est dit que
parmi les mots qui pose question il ya
aussi celui de décider
ah oui et alors pourquoi parce que on
fait comme si depuis le début de la
discussion comme si ce qui est juste
c'était quelque chose qui était
finalement préétabli donc il y aura une
justice à la haye pour tous finalement
nous a paru un peu supérieure lettres
reconnaître et de respecter étant
entendu par exemple à vous parler de
poutine et donc du totalitarisme de ces
moments là où il ya des excès manifestes
dans le les prérogatives que l'état se
donne et qui violerait la justice mais
ça suppose que la justice préexiste à
l'état et donc que l'état ne soit pas
justement l'acteur qui décident de ce
qui est juste et de ce qui n'est pas
juste et c'est probablement la fiction
sur laquelle a longtemps reposé notre
conception de l'état peut-être parce que
originellement l'état tel qu'il est né
dans
l'europe occidentale était un état qui
était soumis à une loi qui lui étaient
transcendante ce qui était la loi divine
ou la loi naturelle justement mais
s'impose ok mais rata peut décider ce
qui est juste et bah justement c'est la
bonne question jusqu'à rembourser l'état
et que je suis mais bien sûr nommé
l'état a reconnu d'abord ce qui était
juste et on va passer d'une justice donc
qui serait une justice naturelle qui
s'imposerait peut-être parler les lois
divines ou religieuse à l'état à une
justice plus immanente qui serait la
justice des droits de l'homme et là
encore l'état dit je reconnais ce qui
est juste puisque l'état reconnaît les
droits de l'homme qui sont supposés
naturelles et dont chacun dispose dès la
naissance simplement aujourd'hui on voit
que l'état est engagé dans un processus
de construction de délibération en suède
ce qui est juste et de ce qui ne l'est
pas puisqu'il s'oppose à lui de
nouvelles questions qui repousse les
limites de la réflexion humaine sur la
justice on voit là la délibération
éthique aujourd'hui se poser des
questions qu'on s'était jamais posée
parce que les innovations dans le
domaine de la santé de la médecine on a
parlé de la crise sanitaire c'était
évidemment l'occasion de beaucoup de
deux délibérations au sujet de la
justice qu'on avait probablement jamais
auparavant ce qu'on n'avait pas eu les
moyens techniques de se poser ces
questions-là on le voit sujet de la
bioéthique tout ce qui a trait à la
fécondité nouvelle morale familiale on
voit avec la question aussi de la
législation dans le domaine de
l'intelligence artificielle de la
robotisation et puis aussi cette
question lancinante qui préoccupent nos
sociétés contemporaines aujourd'hui sur
la justice climatique le fait que
l'homme est confronté aux excès de sa
propre puissance technologique et qu'il
doit se réguler et précisément sur ces
sujets-là l'état d'abord apparaît comme
l'acteur légitimes et nécessaires pour
mener la discussion parce que il faut
une décision collective le souhait de
l'écologie est flagrant
un auteur qui a beaucoup réfléchi à ça
c'est en national qui se posent la
question du principe de la
responsabilité de l'action collective
puisqu'il se pose la question des effets
de par exemple la puissance nucléaire ou
de la dégradation de l'environnement mû
par une excessive recherche du progrès
technologique et là il dit tout de suite
que ça que c'est à l'état qu'il
appartient de mener cette délibération
parce que seul l'état est capable de
faire appliquer une forme de justice qui
est une justice à l'égard des hommes
mais les gars par exemple des
générations futures qui aujourd'hui ne
sont pas représentés dans l'état russe
nous voilà qui pousse l'état en fait à
s'intéresser à cette justice aujourd'hui
on voit une espèce de ballon voilà
exactement le peuple qui finalement
décide c'est le peuple qui détermine ce
qui lui semble juste et qui pousse
l'état à le faire est ce qu'aujourd'hui
macron s'intéressera particulièrement à
la question de l'écologie s'il n'était
pas un peut galvaniser pas vrai c'est
[ __ ] de ce que vous êtes en train de
me dire c'est que vous répondez à la
question revient-il à l'état de décider
ce qui est juste vous me dites non en
revanche provient-il au peuple de
décider ce qui est juste vous me dites
oui non je vous dis que c'est au peuple
de décider ce qui est juste que le pape
est infaillible encore une fois que
c'est lui qui est le soubassement de
l'état par contre je vous dis que c'est
à l'état de trancher et en ça c'est à
l'état si vous voulez qu'on revienne est
exactement à l'intitulé oui oui bockel à
la fin celui ci prend la décision finale
celle éteint mon tranche là dessus on
finit là dessus à vous avez un petit mot
encore je veux dire c'est qu'il décide
ce qui est juste savoir qui décide ce
qui sera effectivement la justice légale
il va décider quelles vont être les lois
la législation par exemple en matière
d'écologie ensuite ce qui est la
personne qui a décidé ce qui était juste
et qui a poussé l'état à prendre ses
décisions je trouve que c'est le peuple
finalement vous voyez j'entends et je
comprends c'est un peu les moules est
d'accord avec ça je suis en partie
d'accord ce cas il me semble que la
question de la justice appliquée à
l'état n'a peut-être pas été
suffisamment poser c'est à dire que qui
s'assure que l'état
décide agit justement de façon juste ça
amène la notion des contre-pouvoirs de
l' équilibre des pouvoirs qui permet
justement de tempérer la toute puissance
de certains acteurs au sein de l'état
madeleine a bien montré que l'état s'est
pas effectivement une entité
homogène mais que l'état c'est un
ensemble d'acteurs et qui est conférée
par délégation une partie de l'autorité
et que donc ces acteurs obéissent
parfois des règles ou des intérêts qui
leur sont propres il ya une critique
récente de l'action de l'état qui a été
fait notamment dans le domaine de
l'économie un parent ça tombe de deux
intellectuels philosophes hayek par
exemple est très connu pour cela et puis
avant tout montrer qu'en fait l'état
obéit à des intérêts parfois égoïste
c'est à dire en fait l'intérêt de ceux
qui composent l'état l'intérêt des
décideurs quand on parle aujourd'hui
c'est un sujet très content pour un met
de la sécession des élites pour
reprendre l'expression qui est cher à
christopher lasch et que les lecteurs du
figaro qui connaissent bien c'est l'idée
que les élites et ce en particulier qui
constitue le coeur de l'état vous savez
les hauts fonctionnaires les énarques
qui nous dirigeants et bien appliquer
des décisions qui au fait ne sont
bénéfiques que pour leur intérêt pas
forcément pour l'intérêt du plus grand
nombre
no comment est tempérée l'action de
l'état de manière à ce qu' il soit
toujours dans les clous pour pouvoir
agir de façon juste peut-être que ça
amène justement une interrogation sur le
périmètre de l'action de l'état une
interrogation qui se posent
quotidiennement dans la dernière es badi
mais justement il appartient il
appartient a pour le coup à la
démocratie aux débats à la conversation
public de décider de dans quel domaine
est ce que l'état est amené à pouvoir
décider ce qui est juste et dans quels
domaines et ce qu'il faut refuser au nom
même d'une idée plus grande encore de la
justice que que l'état s'exprime c'est
en fait amener l'état à être
tempéré et à rester au sein de ses
propres limites pour respecter justement
liberté de conscience individuelle la
liberté des corps intermédiaires
les familles les associations ça a été
très sympa qu'ils aient eu des réactions
par exemple par exemple au vaccin quand
bien même elles ont pu être exaspérante
un point de vue de la mauvaise foi elles
ont été rassurants dans le sens où le
peuple se considère aussi comme un
contre-pouvoir il fait pas seulement
confiance à cette institution et
considèrent encore qu'il est constitué
de conscience libre et bernanos disait
il faut beaucoup d'insatisfaits
d'indiscipliné pardon pour faire un peu
beaucoup quand vous faites de sida
soirée très bien accueilli et
ben voila bernanos pense qu'il faut
beaucoup d'indisciplinés pour faire un
peuple libre et moi conclut cette phrase
j'apporte un petit peu voilà on au
moulin de bernanos en dix ans et il faut
un peuple libre pour faire un état juste
il faut un peuple libre capable de dire
à l'état attention tu vas trop loin
tu vas trop loin ça me dérange ça me
gêne pour que l'état puisse justement
resté dans son périmètre le périmètre
est constamment à remettre en question
on peut constamment le redéfinir voilà
ce qu'on pouvait dire revient-il à
l'état de décider ce qui est juste vous
avez comprise par le jury a fait 18
pages au bac 2 vous avez vu combien un
bac qui les deux parce que vous vous la
raconter la donne à l'atome et combien
vous avez eu madeleine j'ai eu 17 apam a
eu beaucoup de chance et vous jouez à
peu près autant que madeleine mais je
tiens à dire que j'ai à peu près ou plus
ou moins jeunes est beaucoup plus faible
que la plupart de mes camarades de
classes qu'on m'avait dit que les bons
élèves devaient prendre obligatoirement
à dissertation nous ont cassé les dents
sur la dissertation et tout le monde a
pris quant à ce qu'on avait étudié le
texte en cours donc c'était facile c'est
du pain béni guillaume laniel sur
lefigaro.fr teint qui nous donne une
info et nuit le sujet en 1994 bac c'est
le rôle de l'état est il de faire régner
la justice
voilà cela ne présuppose bagdad et à
définir ce qu'il est en fait j'ai passé
mon bac en 1994 d'où le fait que je me
rappelle très bien et c'est ça que vous
aviez des notions bon après si on
continue de madden je vous ai senti un
peu à peu tendu un peu concentrée au
début mais ça va vous êtes mieux et
alors alors sachez plateaux de
télévision mais sachez que c'est très
juste pour vous je suis allé chercher
cette citation de cartes garde
l'angoissent et le vertige de la liberté
moi aussi je peux le faire mais bien
celle là bon on enchaîne les profs
deuxième sujet paul il vous plait celui
là je l'aimais on y va la liberté
consiste t elle à n'obéir à personne je
vous demande juste d'obéir quand je vous
dit d'arrêter parce qu'après il le temps
défile la liberté consiste t elle a
nommé hier à personne allez-y vous avez
la main personnellement le rôle du
professeur ou ci est à merveille à taxco
feraient de bons soirs si beau pas de
sortie pendant la première heure non
alors oui la liberté et l'obéissance
c'est très intéressant de les mettre
directement en confrontation ce que le
sens commun et ce à tout élève quelle
que soit par ailleurs le nombre d'arh
qu'il a passées à réviser le sujet le
perçoit bien bien qu'a priori être libre
c'est subir à soi même et c'est pas
obéir à des ordres qui viennent au parce
qu'on a l'impression à première vue que
les ordres les consignes l'autorité
vienne amoindrir ma liberté oui c'est
moi je peux pas faire tout ce que je
veux non que je suis moins libre est
moins vive l'inde par exemple tourner
sur nos chaises avant tout pour le tout
alors je vous autorise donc sentez vous
libre de le alors en fait je ne peux pas
pour une contrainte matérielle c'est
tellement dommage d'ailleurs c'est moi
il sait très c'est très beau ce qui
vient de se passer parce qu'elle essaie
de vous perturber encore ça ne perturbe
pas du tout ça ne fait rebondir avec le
petit prince je pensais pas en parler là
mais c'est exactement ce qui se passait
quand le petit prince va voir le roi et
justement il ya cette confrontation sur
la question de la liberté l'autorité ce
que le petit prince ou c est ce qu il
veut le petit prince thibault en
indiquant vous en bande dessinée moi un
mouton il va redresser avec le pilote
basque eu besoin de l'aviateur qu'est ce
qu'ils veulent et ce qu'ils demandent au
roi le petit prince et l'histoire shit
soleil ah oui c'est vrai ce qui vit sur
une toute petite planète et l'huile à
l'intérieur des cazals et sa chaise à
chaque fois de quelques mètres il va te
falloir revoir donc le petit prince qui
arrive sur la planète du roi lui demande
un coucher de soleil et le roi dans sa
sagesse du gouvernement lui répond on
coucher de soleil tu l'auras jeu
l'exigerait donc l'autorité du roi
permet de déclencher le coucher de
soleil je l'exigé elle je l'exigerait
lorsque les circonstances seront
favorables oui bien évidemment le
stratagème du roi qui dans sa sagesse a
bien compris qu'il pouvait à la fois
conserver son autorité et en même temps
ne pas perdre la face puisqu'il s'agit
d'attendre le moment où le coucher de
soleil se déclenchera est ce qui est
assez intéressant c'est que au fond vous
venez dire exactement même chose à
madeleine vous venez de lui ôter une
contrainte en les disant mais vous
pouvez vous tourner sur votre chaise
puisque
vous donne cette possibilité
donc à ce moment-là l'autorité n'est pas
amoindrie bon la liberté le dire je suis
toujours aussi autoritaire mais plus
sympathique mais plus sympathique et
surtout vous laisser s'installer des
circonstances dans lesquelles madeleine
peut à la fois exercer son libre arbitre
sans rentrer en contradiction avec
l'autorité que vous mettez au dessus
d'elle non liberté l'obéissance
spontanément parce que c'est
l'expérience naturel qu'on fait tous
c'est intéressant de partir de sa propre
expérience ou des expériences de vie
ordinaire on voit bien que l'homme n'est
entièrement soumis à une autorité qui
n'est pas la sienne esclaves même de
cette autorité le nourrisson n'a
pratiquement aucune liberté parce qu'il
est dans une relation de totale
dépendance et que on le sait bien la
dépendance en particulier l'autorité
parentale va de pair avec des
contraintes sur la liberté mais c'est
vrai aussi quand on grandit on sait très
bien que tant qu'on dépend
financièrement de ses parents on est un
peu moins libres de faire ce qu'on veut
de son temps et de son argent et qui
sont légitimes à nous dire mais pourquoi
est-ce que tu
préféré faire ceci ou cela de ton argent
plus tôt que ce que nous aurions espéré
c'est à dire acheter une carte de
bibliothèque effet étudier correctement
ou que c'est assez savoureux liés
c'était ce que vous reconnais bien là
c'était ce que vous voulez mais à vous
vouliez faire quoi un autre quartier
latin dieu sait si les distractions et
en nombreuses et autres la porte des
écoles et celle de la bibliothèque
sainte-geneviève le nombre de taverne
soldats portant non on distingue mal il
ya des gens qui nous regardent la
débauche développer est ce que la
liberté consiste à n'obéir à personne le
sens comme un ton plutôt à dire que non
pourquoi parce que la liberté on sèl cdu
qu'on ne naît pas libre contrairement à
ce qu enseigne peut-être un peu trop
présomptueusement certains textes bien
connu mais on le devient à mesure que
cette liberté est éduqué est d'ailleurs
une vraie éducation c'est précisément
cela c'est éduquer pour que la personne
ensuite puisse se passer de l'autorité
pour être pour s'appliquer à elle même
ses propres lois pour être véritablement
libre
jamais un argument et ensuite je voulais
un argument qu en fait plutôt un exemple
alors un exemple qui sera pas tirée de
je ne sais quelle lecture philosophique
un peu prétentieuse maristes que l'on
connaît bien même s'il a été un petit
peu affaibli par walt disney qui est
l'exemple du livre de la jungle j'aime
beaucoup aller l'entente permettra c'est
superbe c'est dans le chapeau
vissé
monteux philosophique sans le moteur à
les îlotiers attend avec un peu parce
que c'est moi qui peut hein
alors je suis jeune fille dans les
textes vous avez un compte personnel si
vous continuez avec ses références l'a10
up non la liberté elle est donc éduquer
dans le peuple des loups parce que
mougli découvre à fur et à mesure la loi
de la jungle qui n'est pas comme
l'expression populaire le veut
l'anarchie ou le désormais la loi de la
jungle ce sont les préceptes que le
peuple des loups lui enseigne et c'est
même en fait balouche qui va lui
apprendre les maîtres mots de la jungle
c'est sagesse donc ces lois qui vont lui
permettre de devenir libre et alors me
glisse dans le chapitre ii qu'à un
moment rencontre les bandar log au cours
d'une fugue les bandas log c'est le
peuple des singes ils sont méprisés par
les loups parce que précisément il n'y
pas de loi ils n'obéissent à personne
d'autre qu'à eux mêmes et alors m'oublie
évidemment est séduit par les bandas
rogge il se dit mais c'est beaucoup
mieux les bandes arnold me promettent
même les tricheurs foule a commencé de
vue par le banc d'arles et bien sûr pas
mêler les vandales a bu dix m'oublie si
tu viens chez nous tu vas être notre
chef et pourquoi est ce que c'est un
mensonge parce que les bandas robe non
pas de chef donc il faut une promesse on
va dire que c'était une liberté ce soit
ou non c'est pas liberté parce que rare
liberté vers leur liberté qu il existe
parce que justement ils n'ont pas de
chasse est une forme d'autonomie
complète des machinations absolue dans
la mesure où ils n'ont ni chef ni loi et
ça l'est aussi
patience ça se passe chez les membres
log petit mon dieu sait si dans le livre
de la jungle sont décrits comme un
peuple corrompu méchant bêtes ils se
battent entre eux donc on voit bien le
coup justement de cette absence
d'obéissance et donc les loups considère
que les bandas log n'ayant pas de lois
ne sont pas libres parce qu'ils n'ont
pas été éduqués à 7 à cette liberté est
donc pas réalisé avec les doutes vous
prenez la parole comme ça ne peut pas
vous répondre
ça se fait
une idée à sa marque vous en prie je
considère qu'il faut commencer par obéir
pour ensuite se construire sa propre
liberté cela dit cette liberté là
j'espère que
nous le dira suppose effectivement
probablement un monde s'émanciper de
l'autorité qui nous a éduqués tout
d'abord 11h14 nous sommes en direct nous
débattons des sujets de philosophie de
ce matin sur lesquels sont en train de
plancher les élèves qui passent le bac
madeleine métayer vous avez la parole la
liberté consiste t elle à n'obéir à
personne je vous remercie je vous en
prie de force d'abord je voulais à dire
que je suis absolument de tout coeur
avec tous les élèves qui sont déjà
sortis
oui on t'attend c'est possible oui pas
nécessairement mauvais cinéma 11h14 bah
oui ça y est sortie tôt vous
non
bon on sait plus tu es cannet 2011 mai
2011 ça commence à dater allez-y de
continuer à prêter mais qui est donc ce
qui m'intéresse en fait particulièrement
dans cet énoncé sa forme négative
la liberté par la snel alourdir la
personne mon prénom toujours la liberté
en fait comme une sorte de rupture une
coupure une privation enfin voila on
présente toujours sa com est-ce que je
vais me mettre sous la contrainte de
quelqu'un est ce que je vais renoncer à
ma liberté
comme si en fait c'était toujours voilà
un sacrifice finalement un sacrifice de
sa liberté que d'obéir et ce qui
m'intéresse c'est à qui obéit tour alors
ce qu il dit c'est que le petit enfant
mais n'est pas libre et quand ça
certains grands défenseurs des droits de
l'homme par exemple voilà ce qu'ils ont
écrit notre constitution a des torts et
bien moi je ne suis pas d'accord je dis
que le petit enfant est libre ce n'est
pas parce qu'il est dépendant qui n'est
pas libre puisque ce qu'ils décident à
la fin en fait finalement qui a qui
obéit ton c'est à notre conscience le
petit bébé a une conscience quand même
elle est absolument pas à développer je
suis d'accord tu peux pas y avoir
recours en tout cas on ne peut pas le
savoir et on ne peut pas savoir aussi
qu'à l'usagé qu'en fait on obéit à notre
conscience et notre arbitre notre libre
arbitre qui nous permet voilà de décider
et d'être libre on peut obéir à des
contraintes en étant libre comment
pourquoi imaginons que ben là par
exemple je sois extrêmement et je vous
demande d'imaginer thibault faire preuve
d'imagination je peux fermer les yeux ab
j'ai très envie par exemple d'un verre
de vin et d'une cigarette ah c'est ça
votre solution alors c'est ce que me
dicte ma conscience d'accord mais je
cherche quelque chose à chaque fois que
je prends une décision à chaque fois que
je fais usage de ma liberté je vise un
bien en particulier quel est le bien que
je vise ici je vise fait d'essayer
d'assurer un minimum face à mon camarade
bien organisés rationnelle paul sujet je
vis le site riche il fait semblant de
pas vouloir citer le coup franc j'ai vu
sur ses notes qu'il avait écrit mais
c'est pas grave il y un recours il
pensait peut-être pas la regarder c'est
tout à fait différent et j'essaye en
fait de rester donc je renonce à une de
mes envies pour un plus grand bien et à
partir de là je suis libre parce qu'en
fait j'ai laissé ma conscience exercer
mais j'ai renoncé en partie un nom
pouvoir c'est-à-dire à cette capacité de
donner libre cours à mes désirs et par
là je voudrais en fait qu'on inverse qu
on se demande si on peut pas poser la
question de la liberté de
façon positive finalement à vous auriez
poser la question différemment ou non
j'aurais pas posé la question
différemment j'ai passé tous trop cuit
danse de penser que j'aurais mieux
formuler les sujets que les professeurs
de philo qui font un travail formidable
non non pas du tout non ce que je vais
dire c'est que
quand on obéit à personne d'abord je
pense que c'est absolument faux puisque
je vous dis qu'à la fin on obéit
toujours à quelqu'un et c'est à soi même
si on n'obéit pas à soi-même en fait on
est dépendants or devenir libre c'est se
couper des dépendances c'est ce coupé et
je ne suis pas tout à fait d'accord dit
paul de l'autorité mois pour moi on peut
être sous une autorité tout en restant
libre puisque on a notre conscience et
c'est là que par exemple des prisonniers
ont pu rester libre tout en continuant
voilà obéir à des ordres à casser des
pierres et à être dans la fête un
ravissement le plus total on peut être
libre si on est soit dans
l'asservissement si finalement on
continue à exercer sa conscience ce que
je dis c'est que un peu en fait décidé
attendez je me perds un tout petit peu
dans mes idées voilà non mais j'ai dit
que je voulais payer à ses pulsions
si en fait moi j'ai tendance à avoir des
pulsions qu'est-ce que vous ordonne vos
pulsions actuellement la de vous dire
que vous faites trop long mais continue
et ben on n'obéit pas à beaucoup de sons
d'accord je vous écoute valise et un
plus grand bien savoir le libre
développement mon idée ok oui oui et
puis on est là pour aider les
internautes absolument on est là pour
aider les internautes ce que je dis
c'est que pour être vraiment libre il
faut aussi renoncer à une partie de soi
même il faut renoncer justement à ces
élans à ses pentes naturelles je renonce
à la cigarette vous relance renoncer au
fait de me couper vous renoncez paul à
faire semblant de pas avoir voulu citer
le petit prince et en ça on se grandit
et c'est en ça que je veux qu'on
appréhende la liberté comme une
possibilité de choix à savoir qu'on peut
viser un plus grand bien par exemple je
prends l'exemple alors
les gens vont monter la routine et je
vais vous montrer en quoi on peut être
apparemment sous contrainte mais en fait
libre oui lui livre au ton n'a jamais
été on est dans un couple d'accord oui
monogame a priori fidèles bon je
rappelle que vous êtes journaliste
parentalité absolument alors et je
n'arrive parentalité et donc je précise
qu' il ya un moment très important voyez
vous faites digresser pas important qui
est l'âge environ deux ans l'âge du non
à partir du moment as de ce moment là en
fait on décide quand les plus le
continuum de ses parents mais qu'on ait
une existence libre et qu'on va le leur
prouver donc on leur dit non et c'est
très important c'est non je ne suis pas
ta choses non je ne suis pas toi même je
suis une personne et c'est extrêmement
beau comme âge c'est insupportable à
avoir autour de soi il faut les éviter
au maximum les confier à des
baby-sitters le plus possible à cet âge
là mais c'est une période magnifique
d'émancipation ça ne veut pas dire que
leur française snet sous l'autorité
c'est un placement de produit pour le
film je
voulais des conseils pour savoir comment
dompter vos adolescents vos plus jeunes
voilà je continue donc nous sommes des
enfants non mais je vous ai demandé de
me répondre avec laissant la liberté
s'est ainsi trouvé la personne oui le
projet il ya des contraintes oui donc
l'impasse dans un bar effectivement vous
n'allez pas pouvoir tellement la
regarder pense à mes pulsions mais à vos
pulsions pensez à vos pulsions qui ont
l'air d'être votre liberté qui ont l'air
d'être le libre arbitre de vos mains je
fais ce que je veux de mon corps oui
sauf que vous décidé d'observer quel est
le plus grand bien qu'est-ce que vous
visez dans votre couple vous visez vous
vous dites a priori mon foyer compte
davantage que la jouissance de mon corps
à partir de là vous faites un choix
elles sont contraintes mais qui est en
fait encore plus libre qui vous fait
accéder à une dimension encore plus
grande de l'être humain qui vous
augmente en fait paul je sens vous avez
envie de la contraignant à mon salut si
c'est pour mon souci c'est que j'ai
tendance à écouter à croire le dernier
qui a parlé vous m'avez convaincu des
débuts elle commencer par vous conforter
dans l'idée que vous avez raison d'eux
de croire et d'écouté madeleine c'est ce
que vient de dire madeleine en des
termes du quotidien c'est au fond la têt
sartrienne savait qu'à cette phrase qui
a fait polémique qui dit que nous
n'avons jamais été libre autant que sous
l'occupation nazie parce que précisément
on était passé et que la situation de
radicalité du choix c'est-à-dire
consentir ou résister qui était une
forme pour sartre de liberté totale
existentielle et alors elle est
peut-être pas aussi existentielle en
tous les cas pas aussi dramatique lors
des choix et des dilemmes quotidien
moreau que nous avons à faire mais
effectivement je pense que madeleine a
raison de dire que la véritable liberté
n'est pas l'absence de contrainte mais
le fait d'obéir à sa conscience comme
norme au delà de toutes les formes de
contrainte et d'ailleurs ça rejoint un
petit peu le sujet qu'on avait
précédemment il existe probablement des
situations où la véritable liberté
consiste à choisir justement la
désobéissance y compris parfois au prix
de l'égalité voire parfois au prix du
sacrifice de soi même permet de couper
paul et je vous ai pas encore vu que
j'ai pas dit oui à des zigzags lazio 1
ne me dites pas que vous avez les codes
vais très bien non je voulais simplement
rappeler qu'effectivement et c'est là
peut-être où il y avait un désaccord
légers entre nous c'est que pour moi
l'établissement en fait d'un ordre qui
existent voilà qui est autour de nous
n'est pas nécessairement bon et à partir
de là si notre conscience si on en
revient au premier sujet en fait nous
dicte que être libre c'est finalement
contrevenir à cet ordre là moi je n'y
vois pas de problème si c'est en fait d
obéir à l'autorité de ses parents parce
que notre conscience notre libre arbitre
la visée du plus grand bien nous ordonne
de le faire il faut absolument le faire
et je n'y vois pas un mauvais usage de
la liberté je n'y vois pas une crise
d'adolescence j'y vois en fait la
recherche d'un plus grand bien une plus
grande noblesse de la liberté vous
n'étiez pas tout à fait d'accord donc
sur cette deuxième question le sujet
numéro un du bac techno la liberté
consiste t elle à n'obéir à personne
mais j'ai quand même une citation si
vous le voulez bien parce que j'ai ri ce
duel est ce que c'est juste que vous
ayez des citations sur une feuille de
vous un volume à vous moquer de moi en
plus j'ai lu bachelard deux hommes s'ils
veulent s'entendre ont dû d'abord se
contredire de un homme une femme on peut
reprendre s'ils veulent s'entendre ont
dû d'abord se contredire la vérité et si
de discussions n'ont pas fini de
sympathie dont vous pouvez cordialement
vous détestez et on trouvera la vérité
on vous donnera des réponses le renard
majeur qui nous dit sur twitter à la
madeleine on ne s'écrase pas face à
thébaux ne s'écrase pas du tout c'est
moi qui s'écrase parce qu'ils sont tous
les deux très brillant ce but nous fait
défaut et nous taire comme ça oui parce
qu'il faut avancer et puis abdelkrim qui
nous dit déçue j'ai à faire pleurer les
plumes c'est joli le troisième se loger
je suis pas persuadé qu'il fasse pleurer
les plumes en tout cas des vôtres
c'était pas il perdra évident le traité
a tout de suite dès que je vous ai dit
les sujets ce matin sont ceux là vous me
dites pas que vous êtes persuadé qu'
aucun élève ne l'aura choisira vous
pensez à je pense je j'engage un pari
est là dessus mais bon je suis sûr
qu'ils de stats là dessus on peut savoir
à mon agent que si on trouve un élève
qui l'a traité sinon
on appellera fils carnet du figaro
étudiant elle doit savoir les ans doit
pouvoir avoir ces statistiques alors ce
troisième sujet on y vient les pratiques
artistiques transforme-t-elle le monde
voilà un change un peu las de domaines
on passe du kit d'abord une réaction
tout à mort oui allez-y oui je
m'entraînais à la tonnellerie je vais
vous permet de montrer un renard que je
ne maîtrise pas devant vous thibault
dont certains encore notre organisation
millimétrée et je veux simplement
constater avec ce sujet que je comprends
bien en fait pourquoi la philosophie
échappe à la majorité de nos lycéens
étaient profondément dommage la
philosophie et l'a donc soit pour nous
apprendre à mourir soit pour nous
apprendre à vivre en fonction de ce
qu'on préfère et je comprends bien
qu'avec un sujet de formuler de cette
façon avec un sujet qui semble en fait
si loin des préoccupations de la vie
banale quotidienne vous dites que je
donne des exemples de la vie banale
quotidienne effectivement parce qu'en
fait de la philosophie est là pour ça
oui mais moi c'est ce que je comprend
par exemple j'ai pas vos connaissances
en philosophie et je comprends très bien
les sujets du quotidien ce ne serait pas
lui par contre je vois très bien la
nécessité de la philosophie je vais
découvert avec l'âge adulte à savoir que
c'est à l'âge adulte donc au moment où
la maturation du cerveau à entre un tout
petit peu en jeu il par exemple vers
l'âge de 25 ans
que j'ai eue hier
que c'est vers l'âge de 25 ans qu'on
comprend en fait un peu comment
fonctionne le monde etc etc je pense
qu'on ne comprend jamais tout à fait ce
que je veux dire c'est qu'avec ce sujet
je comprends que les élèves puissent se
moquer sur twitter comme je lé beaucoup
vu ce matin à mdr la philo ça me servira
jamais à rien ah oui d'ailleurs parce
que vous avez parlé avec des profs la
commentent ils allaient avec un
professeur hier kim a effectivement dit
que les réflexions qu'il est obligé en
fait de dénouer toute l'année c'était
des réflexions au sujet de la supposée
inutilité de la philosophie du supposé
manque de rapports entre la philosophie
et l'existence réelle ce que je trouve
infiniment dommage personnes disaient
que la philosophie c'est regarder c'est
vraiment ça l'appréhender sait en faire
quelque chose c'est se demander pourquoi
on se pose des questions c'est la
question qui nous torture qui m'en ont
donné des mines insomnies mais plus tard
vous allez dans la nuit quand même avant
de venir très mal écrit c'est l angoisse
moi le premier sujet sur lequel j'ai
composé en philo en prépa c'était
justement
est ce qu'on peut reprocher à la
philosophie d'être inutile est-ce que tu
est intéressant c'est la question ne
portait pas sucre savoir si elles
étaient inutiles ou non ce qui semblait
presque déjà présupposés par la question
mais si on est en droit de lui reprocher
au fond est-ce que la noblesse de la
philosophie n'est pas précisément d'être
inutile mais ce n'est pas la question
mais je sais ce sens est en train de
noter qu'on essaie par tous les moyens
reporter leur fatigue celle ci est vrai
jeu je salue d'ailleurs chris corrèze
qui nous disait bonjour déjà bonjour
chris brown et j'adore la fio c'est quoi
déjà le sujet sur la liberté alors on
voulait redonne on va traiter ce sujet
les deux premiers sujets qu'on va
traiter ensemble et vous pouvez voir en
replay bien sûr revient-il à l'état de
décider ce qui est juste la liberté
consiste-t-elle anneaux berra personne
voilà pour les deux premiers sujets on y
va dans ce dans ce troisième thème les
pratiques artistiques transforme-t-elle
le monde paul vous êtes chaud allez-y
c'est le moment pénible candidats ayant
vu qu'il n'a absolument aucune
connaissances utiles sur les autres
sujets obligé de choisir celui qui lui
restent et qui n'est par définition pas
nécessairement celui qui l'aurait
choisie et pour une raison très simple
c'est qu'on révise souvent assez peu
quand même faut bien dire la philosophie
esthétique qu en fait très souvent on
laboure même assez peu en cours sauf
quand on a la chance d'avoir un bon
professeur de philosophie qui a le temps
de traiter le problème dans le temps
imparti ce qui me semble quand même
relativement impossible vu l'ampleur des
thèmes à traiter en une seule petite
année
les pratiques artistiques ces contrées
jolie déjà n'embêtera ici c'est à la
fois pas de création par exemple danser
un peu posé la question le libellé pose
les mêmes questions à vous poser des
questions à
partir de là je vous demande des
réponses non et je les ai fait ça fait
la philosophie c'est pas nécessairement
trouver les réponses à cette élection
oui mais alors là moi je
j'ai envie de dire mais l'internaute
regarder on vous dit ce qu'il faut
contre élections non mais c'est se poser
des questions effectivement nous on
s'est dit c'est pratique artistique et
ce n'est pas l'art généralement ou là
les oeuvres artistiques ou la création
artistique c'est que le sujet veut
inviter à réfléchir sur la notion même
de pratique qu'est ce que c'est que
pratiquer l'art alors on arrivait chez
avec madeleine en bon petit les élèves
un peu studieux alors l'art d'accord ça
veut tout dire en question comment est
ce qu'on le définisse finalement tout
c'est à dire que mais moi aussi je vais
du mas rire et regardant la fête de la
musique ou aux caraïbes à la question
est-ce parce que je fais une pratique à
re-tester madeleine allait même jusqu'à
parler du lipdub n'en parlons pas du
lait bio du flashmob dansée
qu'artistique pratique artistique ça
peut dire vont enfin voulant dire tout
et son contraire c'est à dire que là si
jamais on décide de se couper tous en
même temps mais dans une démarche je
voyais esthétique alors et dire qu'on
est dans une démarche semblable
performance absolument une escale à san
siro large trop globale c'est justement
le 1 peut-être un peu le prisme
contemporain on a un regard sur l'art
qu'est précisément
un petit peu obnubilé par là ne sont
performants c'est finalement la pratique
vaut plus que l'oeuvre elle-même ou
parfois l'oeuvre se confond avec la
pratique serre que le geste créateur
devient à lui-même une oeuvre d'art bon
mais si ce sujet qui effectivement
tourné de façon peut-être un petit peu
irritante et un peu trop contemporaine
ne surprend c'est aussi parce que on a
le sentiment que la transformation du
monde échoit au fond à toutes et à tous
de pratiquer humaines qu'elles soient
artistiques ou non alors à moins de dire
que tout ce que fait l'homme est
artistique ce qui peut se défendre c'est
un petit peu facile c'est un peu jouer
sur les mots
est ce que au fond tout ce qu'entreprend
l'homme ne consiste pas à transformer la
tête qu'en fait le terme transformer et
piégeux désormais c'est finalement
prendre du monde pour en faire quelque
chose et à partir de là on transforme le
monde prendre sa matière pour en faire
quelque chose je veux construire un lit
je prends du bois en sage de transforme
le monde le bois du monde devient mon
lit mais transformer le monde ça peut
aussi dire retour à l'envoyeur qu'est ce
que moi j'ai comme influence sur le
monde qui va le changer est-ce que
lorsque je me promène qu'est ce qui
n'est pas une démarche artistique à
moins de le faire de façon
particulièrement je ne sais pas moi
chatoyantes comme vous le faites par
exemple une biche ont bien exactement
lorsqu'elle marche
comme ça
parce que c'est une pratique artistique
je suis passé a reçues de certains mais
on peut on peut demander à des
expériences et notre hymne est une forme
et dans la terre en sahel transformer le
monde mais nous paraît on nous a paru en
tout cas que le sujet alors attendez je
vous coupe vous êtes en train de me
remettre en cause de sujets moi ce que
je vous demande non de répondre à
l'accueil sujet d'aller plus loin à ce
sujet sur trois minutes merci je remets
un sujet en problématique il faut
toujours aller plus loin en fait il faut
toujours se demander très prosaïquement
mais qui est
l'enfoiré excusez moi pour le terme qui
a créé cette question est pourquoi
surtout qu'est ce qu'elle cache à ce que
cette question est une pratique
artistique finalement je ne sais pas ce
que je veux dire que de bonnes raisons
de se poser cette question et l'intérêt
de trouver une problématique c'est de se
demander pourquoi on me la posent ya
forcément un intérêt je vais le
découvrir c'est passionnant alors ça
nous a amené du coup à réfléchir à la
notion de transformation effectivement
quand l'homme prend des matériaux pour
créer une maison il transforme le monde
et lui imprime une nouvelle forme qui
est issu visiblement pragmatique c'est à
dire que l'homme qu'au fond beaucoup
d'animaux d'ailleurs
construit son logis pour répondre à des
besoins est ce que cette transformation
change la face du monde ont certainement
oui et ce qu'elle le fait dans un sens
artistique
probablement non world tous les cas
c'est parce qu'on a spontanément envie
de répondre alors du coup qu'est ce que
l'art a en plus et qu'est ce que la
transformation opérée par ces pratiques
artistiques en plus que toutes les
autres formes de création humaine là
pour répondre à la question le plus
simple c'est déjà de partir à mon avis
et c'est ce que les élèves je pense ont
intérêt à faire de notre propre
appréhension des pratiques artistiques
quand est ce que moi je pratique de là
où quelles sont les pratiques
artistiques que j'aime bien que je
connais et qu'est ce qui s'y joue par
mois par atelys le choisit la poésie par
exemple mais là on voit bien que la
poésie c'est le fait d'assembler des
mots qui vont émettre du sens mais sympa
simplement du sens au sens où quand on
rédige un règlement de copropriété ont
produit du sens on voit bien que là il
ya une recherche de sens qui va viser à
exprimer quelque chose de fondamental
sur une forme de vérité première du
monde ou à tout le moins une forme de
parole de louanges de qui reconnaît et
qui salue la beauté du monde exprimer la
beauté c'est déjà effectivement
transformé des mots en leur imprimant un
sens mais en le faisant dans une
direction qui vise et bien à
à exprimer une vérité qui finalement se
rajoute à la somme de à la somme des
paroles qui ont déjà été émises depuis
la nuit des voix là absolument une fête
un rôle supplémentaire
et porter un message
dans le monde et en sort je pense que se
contredira pas puisque je n'enseigne à
peu près d'accord sur la question que il
y a une visée en fait performative dans
l'arbre dans la pratique artistique dans
le flash mob il ya une volonté
d'imprimer une trace et en ça on reprend
exactement l'intitulé du sujet les
pratiques artistiques transforme-t-elle
le monde posons nous la question de
voltage de transformer déjà parce qu'il
ya la question en fait de la visée et
puis à la question de l'effet
que je vous écoute et avec ou non
médicaux bastonner danseuse est non mais
non effectivement on a cherché du coup
quelle était cette signification du
geste artistique en tant que tel je les
jeux souvenirs sur cette belle phrase
que j'aime beaucoup de bonheur et tu
m'as donné tabou et j'en ai fait deux
lorsque tu m'apportes état matière pas
simplement les mots mais aussi
simplement ta chair tout ce qui fait la
réalité quotidienne de ce que tu vis et
de cette matière bourreuse fangeuse j'en
ai fait de l'or c'est à dire que il ya
une forme de d'alchimie que peu le poète
que peu l'artiste dont il a peut-être le
secret et qui fait ce que l'on appelle
le talent ou la capacité pour certain
art et justement précédent à nous
émouvoir par l'expression de vérité plus
belle que de simple assemblage de mots
et j'en ai fait de l'or c'est à dire que
j'ai ajouté quelques chose au monde le
peut-être que la pratique artistique ne
fait pas que transformer le monde mais
qu'elle augmente et c'est pas tout à
fait la même chose
en dans la physique la voisine ancienne
qu' il ya une conservation d
des éléments et que en fait la matière
n'apparaît pas par magie rien ne se perd
rien ne se crée mais tout n'est que de
la transformation bien peut-être que
l'ordre physique de la matière n'est pas
le même que dans l'ordre at et
artistique où on peut rajouter quelque
chose ce n'est pas la même chose pour le
pour le monde que d'avoir un amas de
pierres ou que d'avoir une cathédrale et
l'acte de construire la cathédrale
fait peut-être plus que transformer le
monde j'ai une question pour vous là
j'arrive moi je sais pas vos
connaissances en philo j'arrive devant
mon sujet je me pose une question un peu
un peu basique mais par exemple dans
n'importe quelle dictature régimes
autoritaires 2013 quels sujets vous
aviez je me souviens plus mais j'ai eu
40 a figuré bas mais non je prenne yann
bon voilà je me permets de le dire quand
même ce qui se passe on raconter avec
leur bonne note non ce que je voulais
vous dire c'est que j'ai l'impression
qu'à rentrer dans un régime autoritaire
par exemple la première chose on
supprime n'enlève c'est la culture et
est ce que si je pars de ce billet est
ce que je commence par là mon
développement ça peut fonctionner ou c
alors maintenant il n'ya pas de en fait
c'est votre réflexion ce qui va
intéresser le correcteur ce qui
l'intéressé le collector je m'adresse
aux lycéens qui peut-être nous regarde
c'est votre capacité en fait à
argumenter vous partez du point de
départ de votre choix d'accord il est
beaucoup moins de départ s'il obtient
réglementaire mon point de départ des
noms si si je pense que dans ce cas là
je partirai sur la croyance peut être
que peuvent avoir les dictateurs donc
dont vous parlez de l'inutilité en fait
de l'art moi je partirai de là ils se
disent que la finalement c'est une
dépense inutile plus tôt il ya deux il
ya de choses en fait ya deux pistes
éventuelles qui peuvent peut-être même
se recouper soit le dictateur a peur de
l'art martial transforme en un peu voilà
avoir une influence sur le monde soit le
dictateur pense que l'art est inutile et
dans ça il ne croit pas à sa capacité à
transformer le monde et donc j'imagine
que c'est une dépense superfétatoire je
pense que la crainte du dictateur est
davantage l'influencé de l'art de la
presse sur le monde mais je voudrais
revenir au terme de base du sujet pour
elle d'être nouveau roman écrit recevoir
le jeu aura un débat là-dessus c'est que
moi je me demande si on ne peut pas
décréter
que l'art est un monde en soi
qu'il est un monde en soi une création
propre et qu'il n'est pas nécessairement
un ajout dans le nôtre alors certes de
pierres ont fait une cathédrale mais en
fait la cathédrale et dans un an la soie
et ce qu'elle a augmenté notre monde
peut-être mais est ce que le monde doit
être transformé par là risquent pas
d'accord en fait l'art doit avoir une
visée politique parce que c'est la
question qu'on se pose est-ce que ou
transforment le monde par le monde c'est
tellement vaste comme mot c'est pour ça
aussi que ce sujet mérite un tout petit
peu je trouve que c'est trop vaste je
vais vous irrite tous les deux mais vous
y allez vous avez compris que les élèves
seront les premiers à s'en moque et donc
sur les réseaux sociaux nous le verrons
tout à l'heure je pense que c'est ce
sujet là dont ils vont les premiers
rires
donc le monde c'est extrêmement large
qu'est-ce qu'on veut se demander c'est
pas la société faisons confiance encore
une fois à ceux qui ont écrit de sujets
c'est pas la société donc je ne pense
pas qu'ils se posent la question de la
visée politique de l'art je pense qu'il
se pose réellement la question de la
transformation de la matière du monde
vous disais que nous n'étiez pas
d'accord avec un point avec quoi vous
pouvez ne pas être d'accord dans ce que
j'ai dit ouais je suis pas d'accord avec
le fait que l'art est dans un monde à
part sir que cette espèce d'autonomie
dollar
c'est pas supérieur cette fois quelques
madeleines dit que c'est à part et là où
je fais d'accord c'est que la cathédrale
elle reste dans le reste dans le monde
de la vie ordinaire puisque précisément
au détour d'une ruelle le touriste qui
était venu à paris seulement pour voir
la tour eiffel peut être surpris il ya
un temps positivement surpris de
découvrir notre dame alors une fois il
m'est même arrivé d'être avec deux
touristes qui ne sait même pas que
c'était face à notre dame et qui
pointait sur leur guide
mots notre dame en disant est ce que
c'est ce que vous savez aussi il était
évidemment devant sur le parvis mais
voyez bien qu'il ya une possibilité dans
l'art de justement surgir dans
l'expérience ordinaire et que c'est pour
ça qu'il ya pas du tout d'autonomie du
monde de l'art parce que même le plus
même lettre le moins doué de sens
artistique peut malgré tout face à une
oeuvre qui est sublimement belle
justement ressentir cette émotion c'est
la capacité qu'a je ne sais pas quelle
contradiction parce qu'il ya eu il ya eu
malentendu moi je ne dis pas que l art
est un monde à part qu'ils devraient
être enfermés dans des musées qui ne
devraient normalement
celui des ma part comme ça je pensais
que ce serait un débat en fait on essaie
tout ça me plaît mais j'aime boumala
n'ont écouté ce que je dit paul c'est
qu' il ne doit pas nécessairement visait
à transformer le monde alors je reprend
les termes du sujet on ne demande pas de
l'art doit transformer le monde je suis
d'accord mais je ne comprends pas qu'on
en attendant fait tant de l'art l'art
nous surprend l'arnoult je ne sais pas
nous saisit je ne comprends pas pourquoi
est ce qu'on voudrait vos touristes par
exemple elle m'amuse elle se retrouve
face à notre dame elles ne savent même
pas qu'elles sont face à notre dame
visiblement la présence de notre dame a
pas beaucoup transformé leur monde voyez
il ya cette espèce de alors pas de temps
non mais c'est lui qui avez vous
conscience naturel entrant enfin devant
un tel ou tel vitrail larosace elles se
sont pas ébloui justement nouveautés
qu'elle sait pas imaginer à il a pas
tort oui mais moi ce que je dis c'est
que en dix ans l'art transforme le monde
comme en plus on trouve tout ce qu'on
vit dans un monde imparfait on va
demander à l'art d'assurer une fonction
qui n'est à mon avis pas la sienne l'art
n'est pas un élu de la 5e
circonscription du val d'oise l'art
n'est pas là pour faire de la politique
l'art est là pour exister en tant que
soient frappés touché émouvoir
éventuellement alors je suis plutôt
d'accord pour le coup avec ce que vous
dites mais justement ça je vais essayer
de résumer un peu le le raisonnement
qu'on a fait ça nous a amené à préciser
le terme transformer c'est à dire qu'on
est parti du principe que de toute façon
toutes pratiques humaines et des
transformatrices et que les pratiques
artistiques du cool étaient au même
titre probablement que les autres mais
qu'il s'agissait de spécifier quelle
était la transformation qui incombait à
l'art soit parce qu'on lui en donne le
devoir ça parce qu'il est dans la nature
de toutes façons de l'art de produire
cette transformation et ça nous a peut
être amené à vous fais toi que
voulez-vous distinction je crie pour
manifester comme dans un coût et sans
rien me plaisent il ya les changements
parti et la transition donc
ça ne va amener peut-être à réduire le
champ des pratiques artistiques en
disant au fond ne peut-il prétendre que
la pratique qui justement opère une
transformation qui aurait même temps une
création qui en même temps est un ajout
non pas simplement transformation mai
irruption d'une forme de beauté qui
permet le saisissement convient de qu'on
vient de décrire et donc ça te permet
peut-être de resserrer un petit peu de
répondre à la question c'est est-ce que
tout tout est art est ce que tout le
monde peut être artiste probablement pas
à moins de galvauder le sens du mot
précisément parce que il y a dans la
menace terroriste bat pas spécialement
justement c'est pour ça que je vais
surtout d'humilité et est en ce moment
encore moi surtout si vous m'interrompez
et donc et donc et donc du coup se
pratique artistique peut-être qu'on les
reconnaît justement au fait qu'elles ne
sont pas simplement transformatrices
mais probablement aussi créatrices et
peut-être créatrice et ben créatrice est
à dire ce que j'essaie de développer
avec cette idée que c'est le manuel le
la transformation consiste simplement à
donner une forme une forme qui est
neutre et qui est donc
n'augmente pas ne rajoute pas de matière
alors que l'as fait surgir des vérités
qui n'existait pas avant d'être formulé
une fois que le poète a été capable de
décrire avec une précision et une beauté
saisissante une une vérité première un
éblouissement une expérience que c'est
en fait je vais direct des mots plus
simples où on envoie les internautes d'y
laisser parler madeleine son nom ça déjà
ça me va en faire regardez moi on a en a
quotidiennement cette expérience quand
on lit et j'espère que ceux qui nous
regardent lise un petit peu et se
rendent compte que quand on lit parfois
on a envie de dire je le savais je le
pensais déjà mais c'était moins bien et
une fois que l'auteur ne dit peut-être
pas que je te prie qui une fois que vous
tiendrez pas que l'auteur l'a dit et
bien on a l'impression d'accéder à une
vérité qui n'existait pas de façon aussi
nette pour nous on a accédé à quelque
chose de nouveau et c'est à mesure que
justement ces expériences artistiques se
manifeste à nous que bien notre rapport
au monde lui-même est augmentée allez
vous avez envie de répondre mais on a
perdu un fils dans l'assemblée ce qu'on
va terminer en s'accordant ce qui
malheureusement n'ont cédé on se
disputera plus tard sur un autre sujet
peut-être donc ce que je veux dire c'est
qu'absolument en fait on parlait de
c'est quoi ces pratiques artistiques oui
c'est ça non bien sûr les pratiques à le
pratiquer à transforme-t-elle le monde
voilà où c'est très intéressant en fait
que ce terme soit 6 général maintenant
je le comprends maintenant qu'on on
vient la fin de notre discussion seront
tard la forme la capitale en fait évoque
les faits les faits qu'à l'art et je
pense que c'est par l'effet qu'on peut
déterminer si c'est de l'art
si quelque chose se produit en nous si
le monde augmente en nous si notre
vision du monde se modifie s'agrandit ce
sublime alors je pense qu'on peut
qualifier une pratique de pratiques
artistiques dans le sens où à nous à
éveiller à plus large que nous ce que
paul vous vous accordez avec moi là
dessus est-ce qu on se dispute on
annonce les dix ans détient
effectivement beaucoup plus juste ce que
j'ai essayé de me la droite demande
exprimée travaux est d'accord alors mon
cher paul je suis désolé de vous dire
françois carmignola sur lefigaro.fr la
jeune dame a donc raison de parler de
l'art comme un monde c'est la bonne
conclusion à mon avis voilà bah je vous
dis ce qui sort de shiloah lyonnaise
mais non je ne sais pas françois ducloux
vous nous faites un petit message qui
est bon vous savez quoi vous m'avez
impressionné bravo parce que vous avez
répondu à mes questions mais un
terrorisé sa soeur de trois et que le
travail qu'on a fait avec le travail du
brouillon qui fait la partie
regardez par une magie une wii sur votre
téléphone dans les toilettes en trichant
merco pied parce qu'on dit non ils ont
été très bons c'est vrai alors rien
dernier sujet qu'on a qu'on n'a pas pu
traiter mon papa le traité rue je vous
embête rep ah c'est le second sujet du
bac technologique est il juste de
défendre ses droits par tous les moyens
voilà on n'avait pas le temps il n'avait
pas le temps quand même pas mal en une
heure et quart le temps que souley nous
à reyers aurait donné lieu à des
débordements moi j'en ai aujourd'hui
comme des bastions pas de ce sujet
madeleine merci alors quand même parce
que vous savez j'aime bien les petites
stations et puis celle là je voulais
vous la connaissez mieux que moi c'est
notre devise ici sans la liberté de
blâmer il n'est point d'éloge flatteur
madeleine vous à blâmer mon cher paul
mais c'était en fait un compliment
j'attends maintenant des loges sachet
merci à tous les deux d'être venus
soyouz à la mairie si j'ai bégayé ça m'a
plu vous avez payé un paquet de fois
malheureusement et je vous avais fait
excellentes pâle merci beaucoup merci
simon refait salle vite l'année
prochaine peut-être kg 1 on va réviser
oui évidemment excellente journée sur
figaro live avec eux tous les
rendez-vous point de vue à 18h
évidemment si on reste ensemble bonne
journée n'oubliez pas de voter dimanche